[Music]
hey sweet little bear do you like being
tickled bears can be cute but for most
people
bear encounters aren't anything like
that here's how to meet a bear and come
out alive according to science
statistically bears shouldn't be your
biggest concern while hiking in the
forest they don't normally attack people
for no apparent reason not unless
they're startled or starving if you do
meet a bear angry with you about the
intrusion what should you do
should you run for your life pretend to
be dead or attack him before he attacks
you well the first thing to know about
bears they aren't all the same before
choosing your survival strategy you'd be
wise to identify the bear running toward
you the first bear on our list is the
brown bear also known as the grizzly
color medium to dark brown body length
200 centimeters body features round ears
long claws and a slight hump above the
shoulder if you go hiking in the woods
of Canada or Russia be prepared for a
date with a grizzly firearm leave that
thing at home a study of bear human
conflicts prove guns to be ineffective
when encountering a bear but bear spray
is a different story
carry it in your front pocket if a brown
bear attacks you you'll only have a few
seconds to fire and don't run bears are
fast and they will catch you better to
fall into the fetal position protect
your head neck and stomach if a grizzly
keeps attacking you play dead once the
bear doesn't see a threat in you they'll
leave but first they'll make sure you're
absolutely dead it's better to stay down
for at least 20 minutes after an attack
just in case
moving on to number two the black bear
color from black to light blonde body
length 150 centimeters body features
straight facial profile taller ears and
short claws black bears aren't as big or
as aggressive as Grizzlies but they
might attack you if they feel threatened
whatever you do here don't play dead
these guys don't fall for that don't try
to climb a tree either black bears are
much better climbers than you instead
get big get loud and act as aggressively
as you can and don't forget about your
bear spray it works for all bears
finally the most recognizable bear of
all the polar bear color white body
length 210 to 330 centimeters whoa body
features short tail and massive paws if
you find yourself alone in the Arctic
and the largest land carnivore on earth
is running at you you've got yourself in
some big trouble for a polar bear your
prey at first sight you won't scare them
so easily with intimidation fighting a
one-ton polar bear not a great idea
either
once again bear spray is your best bet I
mean this is not an ad for bear spray
but you should get some of this stuff
you're running into a lot of bears if
you do end up fighting the bear attack
as if your life depends on it because it
does try to aim for the nose or the eyes
and watch out for those deadly paws
ultimately the best way to survive is to
avoid an encounter in the first place
lucky for you most bears will retreat
when they hear you coming before you
even know they're around still worried
let me just say that you've got a higher
chance of dying from a wasp sting than
you do from a bear attack sometimes you
can get hurt when you least expect it
got a stay tuned for more survival how
to's according to science